[Music]
it seems everyone is getting in the
Super Bowl Spirit including zoo animals
all over the country we're talking
elephants orangutans giraffes even a
stingray all making their
prognostications for the big game the
animals usually are given a treat
representing both teams then Cokes to
choose one so here's the breakdown of
the ones that we found this week since
we don't think that any one species has
any additional football insight into any
other wouldn't you know it as you can
see it is a tie so we go to the Maryland
Zoo and these miniature Mediterranean
donkeys to have us find out once and for
all the wear
Kansas City
Chiefs
it's a tie why is it a tie because they
both they each one picked a different
team clearly the guy with the one guy
got him no but he got out first that's
why yeah you know he was surprised not a
look here's the replay I mean go to it
instantly he was out first he goes over
to you yeah and then another pick yeah
it should have been fast maybe that
means the Chiefs are up at half-time
I don't know I don't know